The goal of modules is to support modular design. That shouldn't be too
surprising, that's where the name modules comes from. And what that means is
that if we have a large system, we can break it down into pieces. And the
important thing about how we break it down into pieces is that in order to
understand the whole system, we don't need to understand all the details of all
the pieces at once. We can understand each piece by itself. So to understand the
red piece we only need to understand the red piece, we don't need to know the
details of the blue and the green piece. The only thing we need to understand
about the green piece is the interface between the red piece and the green
piece. Similarly if we're working on the green piece. We don't need to
understand all the details of the red piece and the blue piece. We just need to
understand the interfaces between the pieces.